peu
[Musique]
dans un jardin qui ne devait durer
qu'une nuit et qui a été spécialement
créée par ce poète en paysage et roberge
au fait vous allez assister au gala
élégance et automobile
[Musique]
en même temps que les membres du jury en
même temps que les spectateurs
vous voyez se dérouler devant vous la
finale du rallye du coton longues fibres
regardez la bien ce numéro 16 regardez
bien toutes les concurrentes finalistes
de cannes de paris du touquet de
bordeaux de toutes les villes l'une
d'elles la gagnante fera un merveilleux
voyage et elle sera désignée quand le
jury aura fini de délibérer
signalons la présence dans ce jury de
maïté célarié sein droit de madame tous
de lautrec du duc de brissac ce gala
était donné au bénéfice de l'association
pour l'aide à la transfusion sanguine
sous le patronage du comité officiel des
fêtes de paris deux en même temps cela
précède de peu le final
[Musique]
pendant que les notes du jury sont
examinés que les points sont additionnés
et que les concurrentes retiennent leur
souffle et espère nous allons nous
assister
présenté par jean le faucon l'arrivée
des voitures de luxe européennes chaque
voiture ayant naturellement à son bord
une élégante
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'arrivée des madmoizelles
madeleine le body habillée par jacques m
on
[Musique]
suivi de mademoiselle françoise open
organ dit blanc brodé pour la robe et
pour l'ombrelle mademoiselle and de
panafieu habillée par germer le compte
de dentelle blanche est parée de
turquoise
[Musique]
mademoiselle florence la loi est
habillée par jacques aymes de satin de
coton blanc imprimé bleu longue sombre
le duc de brissac mademoiselle constance
de toulouse lautrec organdi et guipure
de coton blanc et manteau bleu vif de
jean patou
[Musique]
madame berges minassian manteau blanc
très sobre sur une robe en dentelle
blanche de jean batou aussi
[Musique]
la comtesse bruno doncieux de chaffardon
a choisi la robe de grand soir de jeanne
lanvin
[Musique]